hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar titled
discovery of a gene microbiome
interaction in lung cancer
lessons learned and future directions
this webinar is part of the microbiology
virtual week
virtual event and i'm susie valdez of
labrutz and i will be your moderator for
today's event
so let's get started before we begin i
want to remind everyone that this event
is interactive
and we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you like
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box
and click send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation
if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing this presentation
click on that ask a question box which
is located on the far
left of your screen as a reminder this
presentation is educational
and offers the continuing education
credits click on the continuing
education credits tab
located on the top right corner of your
presentation window
and follow the process to obtain those
credits
i now present today's speaker dr lee
greathouse
assistant professor at baylor university
for a complete
biography of our speakers please visit
the biography tab at the top of your
screen
dr greyhouse you may now begin your
presentation
welcome thank you to the
organizing committee uh for giving me
the honor to be part of the
uh this microbiome uh keynote speaker
um so as i was mentioned today i'm going
to be talking about some of my research
and actually what's more important i
think today is some of the lessons
learned from this research and then of
course
future directions so as disclosure since
this
is a microbiology conference i am not a
microbiologist
or bioinformatician or immunologist but
what i did start out life as
is a dietitian and then i got my
master's in sports nutrition
and about halfway through my master's
degree i was actually diagnosed with a
really rare form of cancer with stage
four and during this time i decided that
cancer prevention was the way
for me and i decided to go ahead and get
a phd in cancer biology
and during my post-doc right at the
beginning i got
really enamored with the microbiome and
its ability to act as
um a risk marker for cancer prevention
and potentially mechanisms for cancer
therapy
and so through this um first four way
into the microbiome
and all of this training now i call
myself an expert poop collector so all
of this training
has led to my um current love which is
the cancer crusader
with my fellow cranster crusader team
members
and i couldn't do any of this without
them so with that i'm going to start
talking about my
outline for what we're going to be
talking about today
i'll be first talking about the driving
question behind the research that i do
give you a little bit of background
between the microbiome and cancer
and then tell you the story about how
this
first interest in the lung microbiome
began in the discovery of the gene
microbiome interaction
then talk to you about some of the in
vitro and silico studies that we're
doing in collaboration
and some of the in vitro studies that
we're doing in my lab
and then end off by talking about the
lessons learned from doing these
experiments and these types of studies
and then some of the future directions
so let's get right into it so the
driving question
behind most of my research exclusively
is what is the contribution of the
microbiome to cancer risk
and treatment response so as a molecular
epidemiologist i really like to look at
things from model perspectives
so in this model what is the population
attributable factor of diet to cancer
risk it's pretty small
genes contribute some to this maybe
about 10 percent depending on type of
cancer
obesity contributes a significant part
of this which is also related to diet
but we don't understand is how much does
the microbiome contribute to cancer risk
and treatment response so this is the
majority of the questions that we're
going to be trying to
answer today and be walking through
today so let's first start out talking
about
what is the relationship between the
microbiome and cancer because there are
some pretty important distinctions that
i want to point out
so we know that there's a lot of
environmental
associations with the microbiome two
that i already mentioned
diet and obesity also the smoking is
associated with this
where you grew up where you live geo
geography is really critical
um to the composition of your microbiome
we also know i'm sure a lot of speakers
have already been talking about this is
the contribution of the microbiome
to our immune system and even your
genetic makeup
contributes to their composition as well
as the
other side which is the microbiome
contributing to mutations
um and carcinogenesis which will be the
majority of my focus
today so one of the things i want to
point out
is this understanding between cancer
initiation and cancer promotion
so we've known for decades now most of
the microbes that
are actually cancer initiators
sufficient for
initiation of cancer without too many
other environmental factors which is
accounting for about 15 to 20 percent
of all cancers worldwide are infectious
agents
we know these to be hpv
hbv and then of course h pylori but what
we know less about
actually is what are the cancer
promoters and that's what some of my
research
and the research have been doing with my
collaborators are investigating so how
does the microbiome promote
carcinogenesis
so bacteria can promote carcinogenesis
in a multitude of ways and we're still
scratching the surface of our
understanding about this
so bacteria are pathogens they can
inject or some of the bacteria are
pathogens they can inject toxins
or virulence factors that activate
pro-growth pathways
and inhibit the immune surveillance
bacteria can take advantage of the
disrupted barrier function
and induce inflammation and then when
you have this disrupted barrier function
maybe you also have changes
in the microbial composition what some
people call dysbiosis
this can cause immune dysregulation that
affects cancer growth but
also can affect response to
immunotherapy
and this has been demonstrated fairly
decisively
um from several people's work including
jennifer wargo
giorgio um and others showing
that uh response to immunotherapy is
really dictated
by the composition of your microbiome
before you start
treatment and i'll just note here today
as well some of the things that we're
going to be looking at
from my research is activation of the
toll-like receptors through
nf kappa b and some of those signaling
pathways so one of the other things that
i talked about
was diet so diet as we know is one of
the strongest drivers of
microbiome composition and metabolic
function
and i love this slide because it really
it illustrates kind of
this impact that diet can have on the
microbiome
in relationship to this homeostasis
versus
this immune dysregulation function so as
the slide depicts we have
really two important uh functions noted
here or maybe
i should say three important functions
first is this um
small uh this mucosal barrier that has
two components the outside which are
composed of a thin
mucosal layer which houses the hopefully
mostly commensal
pathogens and then the thicker mucosal
layer that protects the
epithelial cells from direct contact
with the microbes
now what's really important about the
diet here
is that by eating what we call a
healthier diet
high in fiber other phytonutrients
that can support the growth of bacteria
that
degrade some of these what we call
microbiome accessible carbohydrates
so they ferment them and they can
produce short-chain fatty acid acids
one of the most important ones being
butyrate which is what the colonoscides
use for energy
this also shores up the barrier
functions and keeps those tide junctions
held together nicely so you don't have
leakage of
bacterial products and when these are
really nice and tight and the mucosal
barrier function is
working properly you have blockade of
this
inflammatory response and you have more
of an anti-inflammatory signaling
however when the diet is disrupted then
you have a
switch from some of more of these fiber
degrading bacteria namely
bacteroides then you have some of these
mucin
or glycogen or glycan degrading bacteria
like acromancia
that will then degrade the mucus and
allow
disruption of the barrier function
leakage of these factors
and then chronic inflammation
to occur and as i said previously
chronic inflammation is a strong risk
structure
for several different types of cancer
including colon cancer
so in the healthy state what we
currently understand
in the colon is that there's a high
diversity which is really critical for
allowing competition and stability
pathogen clearance and immunoregulation
and within the healthy host again you
have this great barrier function
a balance between pro and inflammatory
responses
however what we're starting to
understand now with a lot of great work
from several
uh people that look at piso bacteria and
other bacteria like
bacteria's fragilities what you start to
see is this
decreased diversity and might and
microbiome imbalance a change
in metabolism more bacteria that are
decorated with factors that allow immune
evasion or virulence factors
and then a diseased host that might have
dna damage which causes changes in
microbiome function and composition
and then more pronounced is the immune
dysfunction that
comes along with this now on lung cancer
it's similar but there's some distinct
differences and we know a lot less about
lung cancer but i'll talk more about
this in just a few minutes
as opposed to colon cancer with lung
cancer you really have a low microbial
diversity but you also have the added
benefit of this mucosal
escalator pumping out the clearing out
most of the bacteriobacterial pathogens
and
and a healthy immunoregulation and good
as just similar to the colon healthy
barrier function
and this good immune response or balance
between
the immune response but then you have a
imbalance in this homeostasis
and the lung where we're seeing
is an increase in diversity because
you've lost this barrier function you've
lost this mucocele escalator
trying to clear out you see this in copd
you see it in cystic fibrosis and more
now we're starting to see it in lung
cancer
and then within the disease host again
you're seeing this very dysfunction
along with dna damage and that's what
i'm going to talk to you
a lot about today is some of that work
so before we knew all this information
when i was starting out as a postdoc
and trying to figure out if i even
wanted to look at the lung cancer
microbiome i first started looking at
what was the evidence to show
that there was even uh you know a
reason to look at the microbiome in lung
cancer so
some of the evidence that we started to
find in these early stages was that
smoking reduced epithelial berry
dysfunction which we know stroke
smoking is a very strong risk factor for
lung cancer
we noticed that in epidemiological
studies that increase use of antibiotics
was associated with increased risk in
lung cancer
and as i mentioned earlier copd also a
risk factor for lung cancer
increased bacterial colonization
and also in germ-free mice we also see
that
lung cancer development was reduced um
and those were that were inoculated with
pneumonia
and also one of these factors that comes
along with bacteria lipopolysaccharide
or lps
can increase inflammation and lung
tumor genesis as well and a mouse model
now one of the interesting things that
i've discovered during this time was a
really great paper
that came out in about 2012 where they
specifically
deleted p53 the tumor suppressor gene
and challenged with aom to induce
colon cancer or choline or colitis and
what they noticed
in the mouse model that had p53 knocked
out
in the intestinal epithelial cells is
that you had systemic
identification of lps you also
saw apart from p53's normal
dna damage pathway
function you saw this a separate
function that was
important in barrier function so as this
slide points out in the bottom and the
p53
animals that had p53 deleted you have
loss of barrier dysfunction and
infiltration of
bacteria and interestingly enough when
they treated with antibiotics
you see that there's this decrease in
signaling
of nf kappa b activity indicating
that the microbiome was a component of
this
driving this activation of
inflammation so i want you to put a pin
in this because i'll talk about it
and uh later in from the later slides
so when i again when i first started
into this i was looking
uh to understand even how to do
microbiome analysis so i had to teach
myself those from scratch
um but thankfully julie segre uh was
became one of my co-mentors
and we walked through how to do this
microbiome analysis with their current
understanding which was still pretty
um infantile at that time so most people
were
using stool or saliva at the time
not many people were actually using
tissue um
from cancer samples and for good reason
it's a very low
micro very low biomass type of sample
i would say at this point i didn't know
what i didn't know
um but we i had a lot of good great
people on my team
and part of julie sugray's help in that
was
helping us get trained in microbiome
analysis and providing us a really good
bioinformatics school
bioinformatics tool called pathoscope
which we use to do
quite a bit of our analysis but um i
have a
paper out that talks all about these
types of analysis if you want to read
that
so i want to walk through the study
design for this lung cancer microbiome
so because it's critically important and
i'll talk about
the lessons that we learned from this
later on
and we'll dive a little bit more deeply
into this so
the whole reason for doing this was
because a clinical need for lung cancer
treatment at the time was early stage
diagnosis and so we were looking for
early stage
biomarkers the intent was to use machine
learning
with all of these microbial samples to
identify microbial
based biomarkers that might be good
as a clinical tool for diagnosing early
stage lung cancer
so the two populations that we chose
which is discovery cohort and a
validation cohort because that's
what you need to do to have a proper
clinical biomarker
so in the lab i was in harris's lab at
the time
they had a 30-year cohort of a case
control study of
lung cancer we call it the ncmd case
control study
and from this i would have had access to
almost 400
frozen tumor sections both tumor and
non-tumor adjacent and
over 100 of these were paired from the
same individual
we also had or i gained access to
over 40 tissues from immediate autopsy
that was a companion study
with this case control study as well as
over 16 frozen lung tissue samples
from biopsy people who were going in to
determine if they had lung cancer
also critically important i used two
different kinds of negative controls
now because these tissues came from our
repository and i didn't have
a knowledge of how exactly they were
collected or
could go back retrospectively and
collect um negative controls
i was able to find out
what steps were taken from the or to
pathology and figure out what
swabs i needed to take to control for
contamination
we also did no template water controls
and extraction from dna extraction
reagents
we also use positive controls also
critically important from
a mac bacteria community from the broad
institute
so the methods that we use also
important two different types of methods
sequencing 16s and path biosequencing
for more
defined and higher resolution of species
identification
p53 targeted sequencing we did fish
to confirm the species and we also
uh attempted bacterial oscillation for
strain identification
now our validation cohort that we
decided to use is the cancer genome
atlas which has gotten a lot of
press lately from some of the studies
that have come out and i'll talk about
those a little bit later now this is a
great
and not great place to go to use a
validation cohort
the tcga data is great and for
looking at gene expression and survival
and mutations but the rna-seq and whole
genome sequencing data was not
intentionally meant to look for
microbial sequencing specifically the
rna-seq data
which is poly a tailed in which most
bacteria don't carry poly a tail so
you're significantly biasing
what microbes are that you're going to
be able to
identify so that's why i say we only use
it as a validation cohort because the
sheer
number of um tissues that were there and
it also had p53 sequence which is what
you'll see
will become important later so
like i said our initial thought was to
look for
a biomarker clinical biomarker using
machine learning we identified some
biomarkers but we couldn't
successfully validate those when we took
a step back and we looked and asked the
question well can we
identify differences between the
different types of lung cancer
adenocarcinoma and squamous cell
carcinoma to me the
most dominant types of lung cancer that
you see
so when we did this analysis using
hierarchical clustering and machine
learning we identified
several bacteria that could distinguish
squamous cell from adenocarcinoma
and what i'll direct your attention to
is the smoking status at the top you'll
notice
that the smoking status in black is
significantly
higher for squamous cell carcinoma which
is
one of the drivers and risk factors for
squamous cell as compared to
adenocarcinoma
some of the bacteria that we found that
was significantly enriched in squamous
cell carcinoma included
acidophorax and klebsiella so then we
took that information
and asked can we identify that in our
validation cohort the tcga study and
because we had a little bit more access
to finer level resolution
if we could identify what some of those
actual species were and so we identified
acid of forex as well
and klebsiella both as having
significantly more
enriched in the squamous cell carcinoma
versus adenocarcinoma
and we also were able to control for
several confounders in this relationship
including lung location
emphysema age and sex and antibiotic
exposure
so as i've kept emphasizing smoking is a
really strong risk factor
for lung cancer and so i asked if if it
is truly
um playing a part of lung cancer lung
carcinogenesis and squamous cell
constant
cancer we should find these if we
try to classify using linear
discriminant analysis between other
smokers and never smokers and the
strongest one that came out
from this classifier was acetoborax and
then we next asked ourselves
well if it's if it's truly response to
smoking we should see
an increase in former or current smokers
and that's what we see when we look at
the
acidoborac abundance compared to never
smokers
then we next ask okay so smoking is
really
a key driver or key risk factor in
a squamous cell carcinoma as opposed to
adenocarcinoma therefore we should see
an increase in acidovorox if it's truly
related or truly associated
and that's what we see in both current
smokers and former smokers and what i'm
not showing there's
no association no difference in
abundance and acid of borax
in people who are never smokers again
lending to this idea that smoking is
part of the thing driving
the abundance or accumulation of
acetoborax
in these lung tumor tissues that's what
we're showing here
and then i did one step further we
looked at the
um we developed probes for acetoborax
the genus level and looked at our
tissues our tumor tissues
and look to identify this using
fluorescent in situ hybridization and
this is what i'm showing you here
and then a couple of my colleagues in
the lab
that were more expert in doing this type
of analysis also identify the number of
percent positive cells which you're
seeing in these
couple of illustrative patients um
between 10
and 15 percent of acetyl borax positive
cells
so not only did we advi identified at
the gene sequencing level
we identified it also using specific
probes
and the other thing that we identified
too is the
the species of bacteria um that we found
was acidovorex tympans using pact
biosequencing which i'm not showing here
and the last thing i will tell you about
is
this idea of p53 creating a
dysfunctional epithelial barrier
knowing that squamous cell carcinoma has
one of the highest
mutation loads of p53 anywhere between
70 and 80 percent
the hypothesis was that we should
identify
more bacteria of acetyl vorax abundance
and tumors with p53 mutations and as you
can see here
when we look at the tcga data that's
what we see we see
people with tumors with p53 mutations as
opposed to wild type
have stronger or more abundance of
acetyl borax
in these tumors indicating that loss of
barrier function
through mutation of p53 is allowing
accumulation of acid of rocks
in these tumors but we know that
association is not causation at this
point we've just identified a potential
either passenger but we don't know if
it's actually a true
promoter and so that's where my
colleagues come in
and they have been doing some of the
research to promote this understanding
and i'll just
take a step back here and say that at
this point we still have a couple of
other studies that
support this finding with sido borax
from tyler jacks lab
and from a separate cohort in china that
show a set of wax
is identified in lung cancer from either
tcga or in a separate
cohort so we're at this point now
where we understand that there's a micro
gene association in lung cancer
and we know that acetyl vorax has been
found in tobacco products we know that
microaspiration can bring in these
products into the lung
and now we need to understand is this
just an association or does it play a
functional role in lung cancer
and so with the help of my colleagues
kurt harris and dr
zhang they've been doing a lot of work
doing
uh germ-free animal models um
looking at whether or not acidovorex
tempranz can actually modulate the
immune system
and promote lung tumor genesis and so
they're using a mouse model a tochenous
mouse model of adenocarcinoma
with mutations in k-ras and ganofunction
mutant and
tp and p53 using this creloc system and
so the design of this study
was they introduced intranasally um i
know create
and then every two weeks they would
internationally
at ten and the nine cfus either acetobox
tempranz
or l-gasserie which is a commensal or
sham and then do mri at 13 weeks and
what they were able to demonstrate
on the left panel is a significant
increase in lung volume
with this that a borax as compared to
sham or l-gasserie and we see that then
illustrated as well in the right-hand
panel with a significant increase in
tumor volume
from acetovorax tempranz and what they
also recently discovered
was when they tested for the markers for
um
cd8t cell exhaustion pd1 and tim3
they saw in the acetoborox tempranz
significant increase
in exhausted cd8t cells which will
become important in the next few slides
so one of the other colleagues um
postdocs and kurt's lab has also been
following up with this information
looking at the relationship
between pro-inflammatory cytokines
anesthetic vorax
or club cielo which we identified in
these previous studies
so what you're seeing here is a heat map
with the purple on the left being
the squamous cell expression
samples expression data from the tcga
and the blue being pro-inflammatory
cytokines and what you'll see
is that there's a strong relationship
mainly in the squamous cell
for il-8 and so when he looked at this
and did correlation analysis looking at
ila
we see a pretty strong signal mainly in
the squamous cell with both klebsiella
and a little bit more strong
with acid of borax potentially
indicating that acidovorix may be
driving
this inflammatory signature
he went on to ask the question can
acetyl vorax or klebsiella alter t
cell exhaustion so using this really
interesting 82 gene uh set expression
signature of t cell exhaustion from this
previous study uh
gal at all in nature medicine in 2018
from lung cancer
he applied it to these same samples um
looking at adeno and squamous cell
carcinoma asking
you know is there a difference in this
t-cell exhaustion signature
and he did find a really significant
difference between
non-tumor and tumor-paired samples and
squamous cell carcinoma
for this exhausted t-cell signature
then went on to look and see if you
looked at acetoborax and klebsiella
specifically is it correlated
with this cda t cell exhaustion
signature and if you look over to
the left hand side of this heat map
specifically the purple
squamous cell tissue analysis
the gene expression is much stronger
in the subset of genes and then when you
look at
either adenocarcinoma or squamous on
carcinoma you see this kind of a
weak or moderate association indicating
that
it this acidovorax and potentially
klebsiella
may be driving this inflammatory
response
and be really driving that cd8
t cell exhaustion by constantly
presenting the factors to the cd8 t
cells and not allowing them to be there
to actually
uh regulate the balance of proliferation
in those cancer cells so with these data
we have been able to now expand our
understanding of the
influence of specific taxa
towards differences in carcinogenesis of
adenocarcinoma and squamous cell
carcinoma
and potentially identifying a specific
genus
acetyl vorax temperance that's
associated with p53 mutations
and that barrier dysfunction and now
we've shown a
functional relationship uh with
acetobrax tempranz
and actually being a promoter not
necessarily an initiator like i talked
about but potentially a promoter
of lung tumor genesis especially in
people
who are smokers or former smokers and
finally uh with the help of our my
collaborators we were showing uh
this association with the
pro-inflammatory cytokines and squamous
cell carcinoma
and potentially that it's actually the
acidovorax and klebsiella
that are potentially actually driving
this exhaustion in cd8 t cells
and giving rise to
lung carcinogenesis specific in people
with
squamous cell carcinoma so i'm going to
take a hard
uh a little bit of a switch now and talk
a little bit more about
the research that we do and and my lab
related to this idea
and more drilling down on what is the
microbe host
mechanism promoting inflammation
so when i was a postdoc in this lab i i
was
really enamored with this with this idea
of this difference in um inflammatory
response between commensals
and between pathogens
so there's some strange little blips on
my slide i'm not sure where those
coming from but so the model system
that we use in my lab is bath turtles
fragilis
for many different reasons one of which
is it comes
in two flavors the commensal form and
the pathogenic form which
offers a really great model system to
study it's also strongly associated
with colon carcinogenesis as cindy sears
lab is
shown extensively especially in people
with lacromania
disease one of the things that became
really interesting to me
during this time was the function of
these little vesicles
that bacteria secrete called outer
membrane vesicles
and their ability to modulate the
inflammatory response
so the inflammatory response of the
first lines of defense
is the innate immune response and so in
epithelial cells and immune cells you
have toll-like receptors
that can recognize all different flavors
of bacteria
products you know lps flagellin and then
what we're really interested in
actually is the tlr receptors that are
capable of rna sensing
including tlr7 8 and 3.
so depending on which tlrs are activated
you can get a pro-inflammatory response
through an f-capital b
or an anti-inflammatory response through
ifn gamma
and what are these little outer membrane
vesicles
anyway they're essentially just little
the bacteria pinches off these little
vesicles uh from their outer membrane
and they can contain
uh various cargo including toxins like
the bacteria's fragile toxin and rna
we've also uh i'll show that in just a
few minutes
so the hypothesis that i'm i'm testing
here
is is based on the fact that we know
that rnas
rna viruses can activate our engaged
tlrs
to induce inflammation and we also know
that in tumors that they secrete
exosomes that carry small rnas or
micrornas that
signal in a pericrine fashion and can
activate these toll-like receptors
specifically
tlr7 so my hypothesis is that
it seems like bacteria are probably
doing the same thing
secreting these little vesicles that
probably carry small rnas that are
activating inflammation either through
the toll-like receptors or maybe some
other
rna sensing pathway and so that's the
hypothesis that we're working for
through right now is do or
outer membrane vesicles um are likely
carrying these small rnas that can
regulate or modulate the toll-like
receptor and some
early proof of principle that we first
started to look through
is the tcga data asking whether or not
is the tlr expression even different
in colon cancer interestingly enough
colon cancer specifically
it's it's really significantly reduced
and tlr expression predominantly tlr3
and tlr7 indicating that this might be a
mechanism
of immune evasion that the
these cells and colon cancer are using
uh to allow themselves to expand and
survive some some of our proof of
principle
initial experiments that we've been
doing we've been using
tlr reporter cells this is the
experiments we've done so far
looking at tlr4 reporter cells and we
were exposing them
to omvs for about 24 hours using the
positive control of
lps for activation and you see
a difference between two different
amounts of etbf omvs or
ntbf ombs with the ones from etf
activating tlr4
as opposed to etvf which goes along with
some of the pro
previous evidence published by other uh
folks and we're doing some
preliminary investigations doing
co-culture experiments
with omvs and uh either
colon cancer cells or breast cancer
cells and tracking these trying to
figure out
where exactly are these ombs going and
their small rnas and is it different
between etf
and npf and so one of the other proof of
principles that we were able
to look at is differential loading of
these small rnas
and between npf and ot and etf the
pathogen
and so i was able to do this experiment
with the help of my
collaborator garth ehrlich and um
his also a collaborator josh mel
and we set up this experiment where we
collected rna small rnas from a whole
cell
from both strains as well as
small rnas from their outer membrane
vesicles
and we applied rna-seq and so josh mel
was instrumental in helping us do the
bioinformatic analysis
of looking at and aligning all of these
small rna reads to either the ntbf
or the etdf reference genomes and this
is pretty much showing just rna genes
only and what we see is actually a
really big difference in what small rnas
are expressed in the whole cell on the
right hand side
of the heat map as opposed to what the
small rna is better expressed in the
ombs
and most interesting to me is that
there's this little brick of genes that
small rnas that are actually
overexpressed specifically
in etbf um outer membrane vesicles
lending credence to this idea that
small rnas may be specifically engaging
nucleic acid receptor toll-like
receptors or
rna sensing pathways in the cells
and so that's some of the preliminary
work that we've been doing and we're
following this up and replicating it
with outer membrane vesicles from acetyl
borax temprans using either
a tri-culture model where we have
polarized kco2 cells
in combination with raw gb and goblet
cells
or in my lab in colonoids as well
also following up looking at the
co-localization and sub cell
cellular localization and then doing
some um rna protein
analysis looking at what rnas are
actually associated with these tlr's
using his clip
and rna-seq and this is supported by two
of my really close
uh colleagues joe tabby and christy
saves that we're
doing this work together with so that
culminates a lot of the information i'm
gonna talk to you about
with regards to the lung cancer
microbiome story and now i'm going to do
a really hard uh switch and talk about
the lessons learned and this i think is
actually even more critical
than my research is understanding how to
do this type of research
appropriately because a lot of people
are really interested in doing
microbiome research especially human
microbiome research
and digging in the freezer pulling up
those samples and not knowing exactly
how to set this up you
can get some really bad microbiome data
so i'm going to walk you through how to
do this
so why should you care well dna
extraction
actually really contributes the most of
variation to
studies a lot of studies fail to report
sample collection procedures dna
extraction
and my pet peeves is background
contamination control
so all of this leads to a
reproducibility
failure and lots of false leads that we
don't need or want especially in the
clinic
we want sound valid reproducible
biomarkers that we can use in the clinic
and follow up with
for functional analysis so my colleagues
and i
uh rashmi sinha and emily vogtman at the
nci wrote this
paper detailing out especially for low
biomass studies which i'll describe what
are the
key points you need to keep in mind when
you're doing these human microbiome
studies
so study design is first so how
are you collecting especially if it's a
low biomass study it needs to be sterile
collection techniques which i'll talk
about in a second
how are they being transferred and
stored um that's that's a really big
you know problem right now is if you're
collecting uh samples
and they're being transported what's
happening to them in transport
or you know what is the type of storage
uh material that you're using
buffer or whatnot um also are you
carefully
understanding how you're extracting them
are they two different people extracting
them did you check your reagents for
microbial contaminants so
all of this i'm saying because in two
different groups from the microbiome
quality control group
and the international human microbiome
standards group from both
europe and the united states all
diverged are all converged and said the
majority of experimental variability
from these human microbiome studies from
was from dna extraction so that's why
i'm
talking about this um so passionately so
low biomass
samples are mainly what we think of as
less than about 10 000
uh microbial cells and what
i we were trying to get across in this
um
paper was that you really need to go
beyond just sequencing and show what we
call
proof of life so you need to use
culture-based methods to try to culture
out bacteria from these tissue sections
hopefully fresh tissue that you have
as well as following up with um fish or
fluorescent situation for
those specific bacteria that you're
looking for
and then potentially you know something
like qrt pcr as well
so let me give you um some examples of
low biomass samples that you should
proceed with caution
for for sure fresh frozen tissue samples
paraffin embedded tissues bronchioles
tissues
skin swabs environmental samples
anything that has low biomass
you really need to do your due diligence
and understanding
what exactly each step was in collecting
storing and extracting that dna
because as the example shows here you
can have
two different samples with two different
treatments and depending on how that dna
extracted me was two different people
maybe it was different lots of reagents
you could get contamination dna
so much that it actually shows a signal
that actually isn't biologically
relevant
and you have completely missed the boat
on something that could have been really
important but
because you didn't control for
contamination you're not seeing it
so let me give you some examples of how
to proceed with caution
so recently there was this really um
important paper that came out
with the first author portal and nature
and they did what i similar to what i
did they did
a much more extensive profile
of all of the tcga data now i told you
there is inherent bias
in the tcga data because the way it's
collected
you don't know what the contaminants
were but they also used
blood samples from this as a means to
control as well as developing a lot of
other
controls kind of in silico to
potentially
get rid of some of those contaminants
and then
built predictors based on this and the
important thing is
they validated this
signature or attempted to validate the
signature with
tumor circulating tumor dna from blood
samples from a completely different
cohort
which is really critical important
critically important to validate
and so they were able to in a subset
validate some of these signatures
in in cancer and so the next study that
came out
most recently from the nishman
at all first author in science was a
similar attempt but instead of using
frozen tissue they did
i use a few though their main objective
was looking for bacteria that might be
intracellular in all of these different
types of tissues so they looked at
brain lung pancreas skin
uterus breast and bone and they all
used almost exclusively paraffin
embedded tissues
now if you can imagine how paraffin
embedded tissues are created and what
types of microbes might track with those
from or so you have and these are
historical samples these weren't created
most of them were created new so you
have in the or you don't know what all
the bacteria are going to be collected
on the tumor tissue itself from this you
know
the ink that's being used
the different tools they're being used
to gross the tissue
they're not sterile unless you create an
aseptic procedure which you can
um so then you have the question well
what microbes came in
the paraffin bath are there microbes
that are lingering in there
so they did do some extraction of just
the paraffin to control for
contamination
they also used some specific probes to
look for bacteria
and importantly they also did do some
specific fresh tissue
bacteria colonization to identify viable
bacteria
that are actually found from the
sequencing so they did
do um some of that more extensive
validation procedures like i talked
about but we still need to do a lot more
validation
and better job of doing uh collecting
uh samples in from the start so an
example of
best practices in collecting these
samples is setting up
a sterile pathology suite and this is
one of my colleagues from mayo clinic
who've set this
up for collecting microbiome samples
from surgery
so you need to know what are all the
steps from
surgery to pathology where
the tissues could collect freeloader
passengers
microbes that shouldn't be there so you
can set this up even in very small
spaces
and you just need to do your due
diligence and and go there and figure
out
where all the places that that tissue
touches and can i sterilize it before
do i need to collect samples of the
later on
so another really good paper that
illustrated some um
uh ideas to
can combat this contamination issue for
low biomass studies was the ride
printable principle
from this paper in 2019 so report
experimental design
include controls like we talked about
determine
the level contamination and explore
a contaminant taxa with each study
and interpreting uh the biological
results so
really important so in the last part of
my talk
i'll um tell you a little bit about some
of the huge directions we're taking
with my research so uh really looking
at mainly at colon cancer and the
microbiome response
so remember i told you my driving
question was what is the contribution of
the microbiome
to cancer risk and treatment response
but what um
is really important uh that a lot of
studies miss is what is the contribution
of diet
and the microbiome to response to
treatment because as i
i'll point out in just a few minutes
diet contributes a significant component
to the microbiome composition
as illustrated in one of my favorite
studies which was this
two-week diet exchange between rural
africans which have some of the lowest
incidence of colon cancer in the world
and african-americans and within just a
two week diet exchange with the main
component difference being fiber
they saw massive changes in biomarkers
of cancer risk
uh butyrate increases and changes in
the microbiome composition so indicating
with just
two weeks significant dietary change you
have significant changes in
the microbiome sorry i think my slides
got a little messed up here
and another illustration of this how
important diet is to the microbiome
in cancer response um from jennifer
vargas group
past meaning they demonstrated that um
diet was actually really important in
response to immunotherapy
in fact they found that people that had
been treated with immunotherapy they
found that patients who had consumed a
high fiber diet
were about five times more likely to
respond preferably
to the anti-pd-1 treatment compared to
those on a low fiber diet
indicating that fiber is a significant
contributor
to response to cancer therapy so
this was part of the rationale in
designing this study to look at the
interaction between
diet and microbiome and how it
influences cancer therapy response and
toxicity
one of the main concerns that we see
with
with colon cancer patients is this
huge number of people dealing with
chemotherapy-induced diarrhea
it's really problematic especially
people undergoing full fox treatment
and up to five percent of those actually
die from um this chemotherapy
induced diarrhea and unfortunately
there's no clinical biomarkers
for it um the current strategies are
are insufficient um at this point and
it also has all the hallmarks of mucosal
damage and inflammation indicating that
there's a microbial component to this
and in fact
there was a study done several years ago
showing that there was a
significant change in the microbiome
over time as somebody was exposed to
radiotherapy and
the microbiome in association with
diarrhea so this prompted me
to put the study together to address
whether or not the diet or the
microbiome or the combination thereof
was actually predictive of chemotherapy
induced diarrhea and hopefully maybe we
can use that information to do something
to treat these people or even to prevent
cid
either through the diet or changes in
the microbiome and so
we're going to be recruiting through dod
funding recently
this study to recruit people with stage
two or three colon cancer about 120
individuals we're going to start by
setting up a sterile pathology suite to
collect those tissues
and blood and fecal samples as well as
food frequency questionnaires
at baseline and then before treatment
we'll get another
dietary information stool in blood and
then multiple times throughout
chemotherapy
we're going to be collecting stole blood
and dietary information
doing five um follow-up up to five years
and so hopefully
we'll be able to provide some maybe
biomarkers or information
for diet to prevent or reduce this
burden of chemotherapy induced diarrhea
in colon cancer patients
so the ultimate goal of this research i
hope in the future is actually to
identify
what are these tipping points and the
microbiome
that promote carcinogenesis if we
understand what those tipping points
are and find them before carcinogenesis
gets hold in that tissue then
perhaps we can prevent a carcinogen
that's occurring
overall or improve prognosis
and treatment response and so
understanding what these tipping points
are is a key
component of my lab so i just like to
acknowledge all of the folks in
my lab my two doctoral students julian
dill and my new doctoral student my
career who i didn't
have a chance to put on here yet um and
then several of my undergraduates who
are listed there the tabby lab has been
really instrumental in a lot of our in
vitro studies with outer membrane
vesicles
uh garth ehrlich's lab instrumental
again with the bacteria's fragile
studies and then my previous lab who i
still collaborate with extensively
and kurt harris and looking at
following up on those lung cancer
microbiome studies my biostatistician at
mayo clinic
june chen james white my
bioinformatician
and of course my funding resources there
if you want to contact me i'm at cancer
microbes especially
um if you are looking for a postdoc
position when you're hiring a post-doc
if you have skills in bioinformatics
microbiology or microbiome analysis
please get in touch with me
my twitter handle is down there as well
as my email
so i am happy to take any questions
thank you so much dr greyhouse for that
informative presentation
and we will now start the q a portion of
the webinar
if you have any questions you want to
ask please do so now just click
on that ask a question box located on
the far
left of your screen so let's get started
it looks like we already have some great
questions coming in from our audience
dr greyhouse are there any foods which
may
increase the risk of especially lung
cancer
well i would say that that's a really
great question
most of these foods which increase
cancer risk in general
have been mainly focused on inflammatory
related cancers
lung cancer is one of them but mainly
colon cancer
so without saying specific foods to
reduce lung cancer i would say foods
that are
anti-inflammatory that generally reduce
your inflammatory profile so eating
lots of fruits and vegetables and whole
grains in fact i always just
have giving this a lecture and my
nutrition class
anything that reduces your overall
inflammatory
milieu in your system so making sure you
get plenty of physical activity so
you're not
obese making sure really it's just
eating
a lot of colorful fruits and vegetables
with whole grains as the majority of
your diet i like the 80 20 rule for
myself
it works out well 80 of the time i eat
as healthy as i can
whole grains you don't have to eat
organic you don't need to do that but
you know whole grains whole fruits and
vegetables cooking for yourself
and 20 of the time you can eat whatever
you want and usually that
gets you to a point where you have a
good balance of
pro versus anti-inflammatory mildew in
your body
thank you for that our next question is
what sort of effect
does one's epigenetic have on microbiome
composition
and chances for lung cancer yeah that's
a really great question i think
that's some of the things that we really
don't understand yet
of and that's a question that i have
myself is we just don't
understand very well how
does the microbiome either change or
interact with
your epigenome we do know that butyrates
and
the short chain fatty acid can act at
different concentrations
as an hdac inhibitor so
understanding it has a difference when
you're talking about
lung carcinogenesis versus how it acts
when you already have cancer or colon or
lung cancer overall
so that's a great question we still
don't really
understand what that
connection is between epigenetics and
the microbiome
but it's definitely an open for research
in that area
for sure thank you so much and i want to
thank our audience members for these
great questions coming in
alongside a diet what else can one do to
help
change their microbiome composition and
decrease the chances of having lung
cancer
um so one thing is don't smoke and
especially don't vape
that's terrible um so those are the two
main things that you can reduce your
risk of lung cancer
um physical activity i if
one of the other things besides diet
that changes the microbiome
really drastically is physical activity
if you could see
the difference in the cluster analysis
when you look at somebody who's highly
physical active
or versus sedentary the difference is
so dramatic so i can't speak to you
enough
about increasing your physical activity
and reducing your risk for lung cancer
because when you train your lungs you're
exercising them and preventing any of
those
microbes that might be pathogenic from
hanging on because you're constantly
expiring those microbes out those
pathogens out of your lungs by doing
that physical activity
and when you're breathing in all of
those other microbes it's training your
immune system to be responsive
to all of these other pathogens so when
we think about
our pandemic covid19 and who is being
more likely to get
sick or die from these it's people who
have obesity
um people who are elderly people whose
immune system is
really poor or not um as as
helpful as somebody who's young who's uh
physically active so
i think that would be my answer to that
question
thank you for that and i think that's
actually a really important point right
now as many people are sitting behind
the computer
all day long what diet or eating style
is the most optimal for the microbiome
and
you mentioned fiber consumption are
there any other diet specifics that you
would recommend
well i can answer that really easy the
mediterranean diet
mediterranean diet is probably one of
the best diets that you can eat
for a very healthy microbiome it's high
in whole grains it's high in
anti-inflammatory
fruits and vegetables the main component
of mediterranean diet
is really healthy brightly colored
vegetables
along with whole grains and
you know healthy fats like like olive
oil not saturated fats like
um that you find in an animal meats or
red meats
and with regards to fiber consumption
um you know if you if you
don't if you don't think you can get
enough fiber in your diet there's other
prebiotic you know formulations out
there like metamucil
there's a new one on the market um
called prebiotin
and they dissolve in your water or your
coffee
and you can drink this to increase your
fiber intake and help
you know improve your microbiome
composition it also sometimes it helps
ameliorate some other problems
digestive issues that you've got going
on so
mediterranean diet absolute best diet
thank you for that we have time for a
couple more questions
are probiotics and prebiotics
effective in preventative care for
colon cancer there are some preliminary
evidence out there showing that
mainly prebiotics could be
using as a preventative for colon cancer
probiotics
i am not a fan of right now um because
we just don't have enough
information about these different
strains that they're using
and i um when i tell people about
probiotics
if you are a healthy normal individual
with you know
probably no gi issues you do not need a
daily probiotic
that is just silly um
and you're wasting your money it's like
when you take multivitamins you're
giving your
yourself expensive urine if you take
probiotics you're just giving your
yourself expensive poop so you need
you know for a probiotic you only need
these in special circumstances
especially you know the really high
potent ones you know if you have an
ongoing gi
disorder there's a new one out for ibs
called um
holy ghost or holly goss is a new one
that's
um being on the market for um ibs
um you know for specific specific
situations there are
probiotics but for a daily general use
you do not need to take them
well that's good information thank you
so much we have time for one more
question
actually we have a couple more coming in
let me let me go ahead and give you
these last two
how can one introduce microbiome into
lung cancer
cell lines that are in vitro studies
so so in vitro studies
you're probably talking about the
anaerobic nature of a lot of these
microbes
so there are certain ways
that you can set up your cell lines in
an anaerobic
chamber some of these anaerobes
depending on what kind they are will
last for about 24 hours in cell culture
and uh norm oxia conditions but you can
also set up
organoid cultures so my colleagues at um
baylor college of medicine rob britton
um and his former postdoc jennifer
octune um he's now i think at utah or
ohio
um actually set up these conditions
where you can actually
culture anaerobic bacteria with
um normal or cancerous um
monoculture cell alliance and they've
got that system working out
uh pretty well and in my studies you
know what i'm actually using is just the
outer membrane vesicles so we don't have
to worry
about you know oxygenation at that point
we can just you know take out the outer
membrane vesicles
and then expose them to the cells but
there's
several people um cindy sears lab rob
britain's lab
jennifer rockton have worked out these
properties to
co-culture anaerobes with
standard cell lines thank you so much
our last question is there a huge
difference in the microbiome content
between people who are genetically
in risk for lung cancer and people who
have developed them
due to lifestyle or environmental
influences
uh that's a really great question i
don't think we have
the data quite yet to be able to
address that that would be a really
great study to set up
you'd have to collect a lot of
background information
on and have huge numbers to
really dive into that question but yeah
it's
it'd be a really interesting question
the only thing that we know right now
um is you know smoking which is the risk
factor for cancer
but any of the other genetic markers for
lung cancer we don't have
a whole lot of information on those
differences for
lung cancer between those people so but
that's a it's a great question
that's a great house this has been a
great presentation thank you so much
would you like to provide any closing
remarks for our audience before we go
today
yeah just you know again um we're open
for postdoc position please feel free to
contact me
um if you are interested or if you know
somebody that's interested or you have
colleagues that
have students that um might be
interested in that position so
thanks again and thank you again you've
inspired me to go out for a walk for
sure today
and i think all the audience for their
participation and joining us
and their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted
during the on-demand period will be
addressed by the speaker via the contact
information you provided at the time of
registration
and this webcast can be viewed on demand
for six months
up until march 2021 and lab roots will
alert you via email when it's ready for
replay
we encourage you to share this email
with your colleagues who may have missed
this
live event until next time be safe and
stay healthy
take care bye bye